so
here's the news
i
had coveted i'm virtually certain i had
covered because i had symptoms that
match covered so
darn well i had the sore throat i had
the runny nose i had a bit of sneezing
um i treated it aggressively i used
ivermectin i used hydroxychloroquine
prescribed by a doctor both of them
and the experience and all the usual
over-the-counter stuff that we are now
doing which we have talked about yes
and zinc and quercetin and magnesium and
also during that time nac and black seed
oil yeah so presumably i was pretty well
equipped d-wise
uh iona for wise
all those things were in order and the
experience of kovid was
incredibly mild for me
and it went on for about five days it
was odd in the sense that
usually it basically felt like a light
head cold
and what it was different from a light
head cold in my experience in the sense
that it didn't really change it was like
i had the initial thing of like am i
about to get sick
and then
i did get sick and then it kind of
hovered at that level
for five annoying days
and then it cleared up and actually on
the fourth day i got fed up with it it
didn't wasn't any different than it had
been on the previous days and i decided
to see if i could ride my bike and
actually i detected no difference in my
ability to ride climb hills and all of
that so it was a very mild somewhat
annoying experience it's a little
bizarre because you didn't expose
yourself to anyone except the people you
lived with right had already who had
already had it um yeah and it was
annoying to have something that felt
like a cold and not do the things now
personally i've been saying for
much longer than there's been covid that
i don't think we treat things like colds
with proper seriousness that we give
each other colds too easily because
society sort of doesn't expect you to
stay away
but in any case it was frustrating not
to be able to do things like run to the
market to get something when i had what
felt like an extremely light cold on the
other hand not my choice to make for
other people who might contract it so i
did do it
but anyway the
the experience after two years of
dodging
this virus and obviously i probably had
omicron which is clearly
a different experience than
delta another previous variant but
it is interesting after two years of i
believe successfully dodging covid to
finally have it catch up to me and
have that experience be
be what it was
this also means
that as you mentioned all of the family
has now had covid
we're almost certain of this because the
symptoms are such a close match i will
say
you brought home
four you happen to be at a drug store
when someone happened to make a delivery
of these at home tests and you brought
home four which was the limit of what
they would sell you
each box contains two tests
we gave them at various places
so
we can talk about this i guess but i
know i i
i think i i would never have sought out
these tests
i happen to be as i wrote about my
substance i would happen to be standing
in line at the point that they showed up
and all these people came spilling into
the store having been waiting for these
things and
the guy in front of me and me in line
just happened to be sort of quote
unquote in the right place at the right
time and frankly i bought them thinking
well we'll save them for when we need
them to prove you know because because
we can't get into a lot of places here
unless you have a negative test or proof
of vaccination and we don't have the
latter
and
they're garbage they're total garbage
and i don't like that they exist and i
don't and so basically um i am
i want nothing to do with this i want
nothing to do with the testing i want
nothing to do with being asked to prove
that i took a test that we aren't even
being told anymore what the rates of
posit of false negatives and false
positives are we aren't even being told
like what the source on these things is
and um and and frankly the you know the
the
more
the bigger point is
this isn't a big deal
anymore well but this is no longer a
disease that's a big deal for most
people and you know you could say that
about a cold and no one's going to gasp
and say you're killing people and you
could even say that about the flu
although most people wouldn't say it
quite so strongly about the flu and in
the beginning two years ago 22 months
ago we were saying about and two people
who were saying it's just a flu like no
it's not and it's you know it's it's not
it's different in part because it's been
you know it's it's a franken virus
um but at this point
um with this variant it is far less in
terms of uh how it manifests yeah but i
still want i still want to make this
point okay
eight tests for eight come up negative
in a family in which the people who were
tested were presumed positive
in several cases by doctors by doctors
okay and so my point is look you and i
who also affirm that the tests are
worthless you and i are biologists right
we are not lab biologists but we have
certainly done lab work right so we are
going to be well above average in our
ability to do the test as the protocol
it wasn't a failure to swab right
it wasn't a failure at any level and if
we
did the test in such a way that it did
not come up positive eight times out of
eight because of something in the
technique than it is a flawed test at
that level and if the test is simply so
insensitive that it can't measure these
things how is it possible that we're two
years into these things that we're
distributing these tests without
information about how seriously to take
their results when the tests appear to
be nonsense
second thing is i don't know whether the
lightness of the disease that we faced
was entirely a fact of omicron whether
it was because we have been
very diligent now that we understand the
role that things like vitamin d
deficiency and ionophore deficiency play
to supplement these things we are
extremely careful about this so we were
well prepared but the point is
or the early treatment
or the early treatment or all of the
above and the point is why is the cdc
not recommending the supplementation why
is why are we distributing tests that
give a completely false impression to
the extent that knowledge about whether
you are or aren't positive could be
useful in terms of controlling the
spread of the disease if that's even
what we should be attempting to do with
omicron
right why is the experience of this so
far off of the official recommendation
right why and this is
this is really the crux of the matter is
and by the way if you want to know what
light looked like in every regard the
data stream is polluted in every every
single regard there's nothing that you
can no ability to like there's no place
you can stand and be like okay i'm
limited when i can see there's some
columns i have to look around but at
least i know from here what i can see
about the official counts or
anything you can't trust any of it the
yeah the the officials are blinding
themselves right we can talk all day
about you know adverse events but the
point is they tell us that we can't
trust the data they don't tell us what
we're supposed to infer the level of
adverse events from other than the data
in the very system they aren't doing
autopsies which would be the way if you
were really interested in finding out
whether people who had died in
some temporal proximity to a vaccination
had died from it or just uh it was a
you know a spurious
temporal correlation but we're not
collecting the data so anyway the data
stream is polluted all over the place
but the tell for me yep the tell
is
what happened at the point that omicron
seems to have caught them and everyone
else off guard right at the point that a
variant shows up
which as many of us pointed out has many
of the characteristics that you would
ascribe to an attenuated virus vaccine
as a woman i know
said to me this week who is who does not
particularly follow the podcast or
anything
isn't omicron what we all wanted
well like isn't that what the world was
hoping for back in you know the first
year of covid i will make my usual
caution right attenuated virus vaccines
are the best vaccines from the point of
view of
their interaction with the system that
is to say they properly alert the body
to
[Music]
to the antigens that the body becomes
sensitive to because they are actual
infections right and so the point is
your body knows how to detect an
infection it detects the infection from
the attenuated virus it has the proper
reaction it makes a durable lasting
immunity right that's what you want it
has a slight danger to it
which is that because you're using an
actual living organism right
organism is i'm using the term loosely
but living right
but nonetheless the point is you're
talking about something that has genetic
information in it and evolves and
basically i would argue it is a living
organism it just borrows all of the
machinery from you but
let's put that aside it's not important
to the question you're talking about
something that can evolve right now it's
very unlikely to evolve because of one
thing right the one thing is that the
attenuated virus vaccine that we give
you is not contagious which means it has
a very limited window in which to learn
new tricks that might be dangerous to
you right and so the point is even if it
makes slight progress on that question
if it doesn't jump to the next person
that whatever progress it makes is lost
okay
omicron is not like this even though it
has many of the characteristics of
attenuated virus vaccines it lacks some
of them it's not as attenuated as you
would want right an attenuated virus
vaccine that's really great will have
effectively no symptoms
this one has symptoms and it's highly
contagious it's highly contagious which
means that what evolves from omicron
yeah could be uh more attenuated than
omicron that's one strong possibility
but it's not the only possibility and so
yes
the universe having delivered omicron to
us at this moment we ought to look at it
and say you know what that is
functioning like a vaccine and we ought
to
pivot our policy on that basis right
we ought not say oh
hey a vaccine because it has this
evolving capacity to it this this policy
pivoting you speak of which
is the amazing fact here yes nothing
changed right it was like you could tell
right were they going to have a meeting
and say
you know well in light of omicron does
this booster stuff make any sense you
know geez we don't you know if they're
being honest with themselves and what
they say to us has anything to do with
what they say to themselves which is
clearly not the case but if it did they
would say something like we don't have
any idea what the adverse events are
from here because we don't trust theirs
and there's no other system to collect
them right maybe we shouldn't be
advising boosters this from the oregon
health authority um
tell us how your friends and family
helped you through covet 19.
you have been in bed for two days with a
sore throat and fever you hoped it was
just a regular head cold but as symptoms
persist you recognize the inevitable and
get a test it's cobit 19.
your friends and family are concerned
and want to help what do you need
groceries someone to help with child
care someone to run to the pharmacy for
you or walk the dog
so they're soliciting stories
you've had a sore throat and fever
you have
something in the general scheme of a
cold or maybe even a flu depending on
the variant this sort of thing
you recognize the inevitable
they are trying to keep us so scared of
one thing one thing and only one thing
and this you know this again to your
point and this is why i wanted to
interject this many minutes ago
to your point about the narrative will
not shift
imagine soliciting stories about
the cold
you recognize the inevitable
you're gonna be
not feeling up to walking your dog for a
couple of days
what do you do right it's actually
they've loaded you up with a concern and
then the point is yeah even if what you
should be experiencing is
oh this is an annoyance rather than a
life-threatening condition the point is
they're gonna now collect on having
loaded you up with that fear right right
and they're going to instead of letting
you calibrate how how to feel about how
sick you are they're going to tell you
how to feel and that is you should feel
frightened right
um yes you know that's the other thing
that needs to be said here is
what we experience with cobit was
super mild i do if people want to know
what that looked like frankly i did a
joint live stream with chris martinson
uh an experiment that we did where we
streamed to our two channels i was sick
before we went on camera i mentioned
this to chris and he said yeah i hear it
in your voice so you can go there you
can hear it right you can see exactly
what it looked like and how debilitating
it was
i will say
of all of us toby actually uh defeated
the thing in
you know less than 24 hours of you know
sniffles and sneezes yeah we couldn't
send him to school so he went on a bike
ride right i mean
but but it was exactly the same the sore
throat yeah all exactly the same
symptoms and none of us got new things
from the other as it just progressed
through the face right so we all had the
same thing if you didn't have a whatever
you know
nightmare of a public health authority
out there we would be having a very
different conversation and the
conversation would sound like okay
omicron is sweeping through the
population
it is folly to think that we can control
it right this is so contagious that it's
uncontrollable we ought to protect those
who are vulnerable and there is
presumably an age threat stratification
in the danger of this thing so i may
have had something that felt like a mild
cold an 85 year old might have something
very different we should protect people
from it you know even though it's not
that people can't die from this right
but you know the fact is the nature of
death is such that you you you know you
become fragile and more vulnerable to it
and at some point you're so vulnerable
that nearly anything can push you over
so
turning society upside down doesn't make
any sense so the right conversation to
be having is
in light of omicron
the policy ought to radically shift in
the direction of we can't control this
we should protect the vulnerable we
should go back
we should rescue our economy to the
extent that we can still
do it we should address our supply chain
issues and if something evolves from
this that has some different pattern
we'll get back to you we'll look at that
one then and we'll say what does it
suggest that we should be doing but of
course we're not having that discussion
and that tells you everything you need
to know
[Music]